our second speaker
to okay so today what I'll I'll tell you
about today is uh not so much new work
but a review of a lot of things that
have happened in Quantum expanders uh
which
are uh a a somewhat widely useful
technique not quite as widely useful as
as classical expanders but I think
something that uh has potential to be an
important basic tool in a lot of and a
lot of quantum information
constructions so I'll begin by just
briefly reviewing classical expander
graphs uh and then because the quantum
expanders will be sort of a
generalization of those in in a
particular sense so an expander
graph for for our purposes will be an
undirected
graph and
the the graph is called an expander
because all of the sets are expanding so
what do I mean by that the expansion if
if s is a subset of
vertices then the expansion of a set is
defined to be basically the fraction of
edges that start in that set that end up
outside of it so the
probability over all
edges that one vertex is outside of the
set given that the other one is inside
the set so it's always a number that's
between zero and one it's zero if a set
is just disconnected from the rest of
the graph or if it's the entire if it's
the entire graph uh and it's one if uh
if all of the edges starting the set
leave that Set uh and the expansion
Alpha is the
minimum
over
subsets of no more than half the
vertices of the of the expansion of that
set you have to pick some kind of
threshold like half the number of
vertices because if you take s to be the
entire graph then this this number is
trivially zero uh and once you start to
get to 99% of it for example then of
course no more than there'll be some set
where no more than one and 100 of the
edges is leaving uh and so it's
conventional take this to be something
like half the half the edges in the
graph
yeah this is a conditional
probability this is a conditioned
probability of this happening
conditioning on that happen so there's
no reference to the degree or the size
of the the graph or anything um
typically um I I will consider
um dular
graphs with n vertices I'll also
consider undirected
graphs
uh you can relax sort of the condition
that they're regular and that they're
undirected but it won't really be useful
for me to go into that here okay so this
is one definition one definition of an
expander graph is that if Alpha is
greater than some
constant then we say that the graph is
an expander
and so right away you can see this
doesn't really make sense if you just
talk about one graph by itself because
what do you mean greater than a constant
you know what constant so it's normal to
talk about an expander a family of
expander graphs so perhaps the the for a
sequence of n maybe for all n or for a a
sequence of that that uh of increasing
values of n uh perhaps d the degree will
be fixed and Alpha will be perhaps
changing but it'll always be greater
than equal to some constant even as you
you increase n arbitrarily so here
constant would mean independent of N and
so technically what we're talking about
is a family of expander graphs uh but
I'll do what most people do and just say
an expander graph leaving the the family
part
implicit okay so there's always some
positive for any connected graph Alpha
will be positive um but it's non
you know having it be always greater
than equal constant is is not always
trivial um for example if you if you
take a line or a grid or any finite
dimensional graph then Alpha will shrink
with
n um okay so that's one way to describe
them is in terms of this this sort of
combinatorial expansion parameter an
alternate
definition is the spectral
definition so let a be the nor
normalized adjacency
Matrix so in in
Quantum notation you could write this as
sum over all the
edges of of this
term
and so it's a a matrix of the 1 overd uh
in each each position where there's an
edge and let's say that so so this
adjacency Matrix the top I value will
always be one corresponding to the the
vector of all
ones uh and the second I
value uh let's say it's 1 minus
Epsilon how much this is less than one
so this the value
Epsilon turns out to tell you how good
of an expander is um one way to see that
is if you repeatedly if you consider the
random walk corresponding to this to
this uh graph where you started a vertex
and pick a random neighbor then the
probability distribution will be um
multiplied by this Matrix a and so it
will eventually converge to the top IG
value uh well sorry to the IG Vector
corresponding to the top IG value the
the uniform distribution um and the rate
at which it does it will be given by the
gap between the second largest ion value
and and the top I can value um there's
I'm sweeping under the raw issues of if
the graph is bipartite
um so uh yeah let me let me let me just
ignore that issue for now um if another
I guess if you want to be a little more
precise you could you could say that
Epsilon is the minimum of uh Lambda
2 1us Lambda 2 of
a um I guess 1 minus absolute value of
Lambda n of a if so if the graph is
bipartite then the bottom I value will
be minus one and then you will not
converge you know then you could if you
do the random walk you might just bounce
back and forth between the two halves
forever you'll never converge to the
stationary distribution uh and so you'll
also have to demand that this thing be
bounded away from uh be bounded away
from minus one uh but in many cases it's
you you you don't have to worry about
this condition
um and I'm going to a little imprecise
and just talk about just talk about
Lambda 2 here uh and sort of implicit in
all of that is really we also do have to
worry about the bottom I can value but
um uh but I'll never I'll never discuss
a situation where where it'll be an
issue well the cleanest way to say it is
that all nonprincipal I am values in in
absolute value are less than 1us F
that's right so the I values because are
in a range from minus one to one there's
always an igen value here and then what
you'd like is that they
all live in
this you know just you like them all to
live in this this interval here so
another way to say that is if you take
the adjacency Matrix and you
subtract what so what is the top I value
it's um let me call it
U
where U is 1un n * the all ones Vector
then this thing should have operator
Norm less than equal to 1 minus Epsilon
so you take the adjacency Matrix you
remove the part corresponding to the top
I vector and what you're left with
should have Norm less than equal to 1us
Epsilon that's a that's maybe a cleaner
way of
think okay so this is an alternate
characterization
expanders and it's closely related to
the combinatorial one
uh by the
Bound by I believe this
bound um one way to see this
is this minimum here is over subsets and
so what
the yeah basically what way to see it is
you can think of both of these as as
variational problems
so this is the minimum expansion over
subsets uh and this one is the
maximum of
uh yeah so Lambda 2 is the maximum of V
A
V where we maximize over V that are
orthogonal to the to the uniform
distribution and that are unit
vectors uh so over over particular class
of V so both of them can be
characterized variationally and one
particular class of V that we can take
are ones so so what do the v's have to
be they have to be orthogonal to this to
this Vector U so they cannot that means
if you add up all the entries of it it
has to add up to zero so if they're real
vectors some of them have to be positive
and some of them have to be negative and
one particular class of of candidates
for these things at V would be things
that look like some constant
times the indicator function on some set
minus some constant that's uh times
times the all one VOR so in other words
all the positive values are the same and
all the negative values are the same uh
and you could a restrictive thing you
could do is just maximize over these
these vectors V uh over this over this
restricted class corresponding to be all
the same positive value on one set and
then all the same negative value on the
rest of the entries and it turns out if
you do this restricted maximization you
get exactly something that exactly
corresponds to uh to this minimization
it corresponds basically to to
maximizing over over subsets um and so
that explains kind of the easy part of
this bout that basically
this this relation right here says
that uh said that when you that that
this minimizing over sets corresponds to
to doing the I value calculation over a
restricted set of vectors um what's a
little more non-trivial is this bound
right here so to argue that to go in the
other direction to say if all sets are
are expanding then this also tells us
something about the second largest I Dev
so another way to say that is if all of
these if you only know this this
quantity here for vectors that have this
restricted form being all the positive
entries the same and all the negative
entries the same that nevertheless tells
you something about General vectors uh
that's this this second part uh which is
called Cher's inequality and it's a
slightly a slightly more complicated
calculation still not too bad um and and
it's and you can kind of imagine why
should be true right if you if you can
control this quantity for things where
all the positive entries are the same
and all the negative entries are the
same how different can it really be by
letting your positive entries range over
some some uh you know have some be high
and some be low it's they these
quantities shouldn't be dramatically far
apart and uh and that intuition is
confirmed by the fact that you you just
lose a square root
Factor
um okay so this
is kind of the the the basic of
classical expander graphs
um two other things I a few other things
I want to say about them so one thing
you can ask is what are sort of the
range of parameters that are possible
one thing that's that's often exciting
about this is that alpha or or Epsilon
are are independent of N and there's
another parameter here which is D and it
turns out that the best these can be in
terms of
D is uh let's see so you should always
have Lambda to roughly greater than or
equal to
2un
d-1 over d uh this is more or less the
the optimal that's possible uh and this
can be achieved by what are called
ranuan
graphs uh the reason they're named after
ramanujan is um
it's one of the the less accurate pieces
of scientific naming I think uh I I'll
yeah so I'll explain why they're named
that in a second it's what you want cber
graphs
um right yeah that would be that would
be better I guess so the
uh so right so this is sort of the limit
of of of what's possible is that this
thing scales basically you can think of
it as going like one over
1un D and one way to
um to understand this is we're
multiplying by a factor of of of one
over D for this for this walk so it
could it'll never be less than than
1/d uh and the square root refers to
this is basically the second largest ion
value of what is in a sense the best
possible expander which is the infinite
dular tree so the point of an expander
is everything is extremely well
connected you know you you you go
somewhere and you go somewhere else and
with you're basically going to as many
new places as possible for whatever set
you have most of the edges lead out when
you take a random walk you're very
unlikely to return to where you came
from and the tree the infinite tree is
in a sense the best possible expander
because the only way to return to where
you came from is to literally back
you'll never you'll never encounter a
loop if you if you take this fork and
then this fork and that fork you'll
always experience new places the only
way to return to your vertices is is
just walk back on the edges that you
came from uh and even on the infinite
tree if you take a random walk there's
some return probability if you take K
steps then there's some CH some
probability exponentially small in K
that you will return and this
corresponds to the second largest ion
value and you can calculate that return
probability pretty easily and it turns
out to to to be basically this quantity
to the to the cave power so that's why
you'll never do better than that ramanan
graph saturated uh and this was achieved
first by uh by lubotsky Phillips and
sarna in uh what 87 80ish
8ish
uh and in
the using math techniques that related
to uh something that ramanan did hence
uh hence the name uh
it's also known that random
graphs are almost
ramanan so they
achieve basically slightly larger than
than this value
um and it's possible it's it's often
interesting to have graphs that are not
quite ramanan but merily have constant
Gap this is for most application this is
good enough uh and there are a number of
constructions of this
um
I guess the you know the LPS one is is
one the there's one by margulis which
involves just sort of a relatively
simple group theoretic one and I guess
the sort of the two main techniques for
constructing
them one technique is
to to use recursion so basically to take
a small graph and kind of build up
bigger ones from
that uh and one of
the some of the techniques use here are
the the zigzag product or um more
generally an idea called a lift and I'm
not really going to Define either of
these but
um I just want to sort of give you point
of the literature that these are kind of
some of the ways of of constructing them
basically in terms of building up bigger
graphs from small ones and these have
become very very effective uh another
big method is to use a k
graph
so what a k graph is is you have a a
group G and a generating
Set uh gamma and the vertices correspond
to the group and the edges correspond to
all the ways so from a Vertex its
neighbors are all of the ways you can
multiply by an element of the generating
set so it's all the pairs G time
GH where H belongs to the generated set
and G belongs to the
group uh and to make it unded maybe
we'll say that the generating set
contains all of its
inverses so this is a this is called a c
graph and there are a number of of
expanders based on on K graphs the the
LPS expander is one example uh but since
then there have been many many more
constructions for for many other
groups yeah so what's the hard part
finding the group or finding the
specific generators that do the
job
um probably more the generator I mean
most of the groups
are actually it's some of you more often
it's finding the
generator um in some cases the groups
can be kind of complicated so the zigzag
product I think you can interpret as
being over a being the K graph of a
semidirect product of groups and I think
that's the case where no one would have
looked first at the groups and then
figured it out but they did be in this
combinatorial way and then interpret it
as a k graph um I think in many cases
the hard part is really just proving it
you know you can often come up with it
I'll mention one thing that was a big
open question for a long time which is
to find a constent degree K graph
expander over the symmetric group and
that was a huge Challenge and I think
there the challenge was to come up with
the generating set as well as to prove
it yeah well for kphs like Mar Mark is
that like there is there are groups
thetical restrictions like for instance
it cannot be an ailan group and I think
there is a paper about that that there
are certain even maybe solvable group is
not good but I forgot but the other
thing to be mentioned is that so there
is this recent breakthrough of of uh
like dance spean
like and Adam Marcos uh with the
beautiful construction I mean I mean
based on M linears who who the
authman and
yeah and and Adam marus I
think right so what they have
constructed is um so one open question
is can you construct a ramanan graph for
any uh for any
n and sorry any degree uh the exactly
Roman graphs only have p and p plus1
degrees where their P are primes right
or par primes right but it's still
unnown I mean they answered that they
achieve it for bipart ranisan graph of
all decrees but it's still unknown how
to find them but they I think they did
it only for bipar
right I mean it still answers the
question if they exist yeah you know for
a given degree can you find the REM
the answer is it exists but we don't
know what it is right but I guess what I
mean is a bipar expander is a slightly
you know slightly different a different
object right so yeah but the main
question is still open still open that's
right yeah so um right so these LPS
things are based on on particular groups
the groups correspond to 2x two matrices
over FP uh or over over finite fields
and so the degree is sort of constrained
by this thing and only some degrees are
possible and some values of n are
possible uh and what Marcus uh Spielman
FAS do
is uh attempt to resolve the question of
can you construct a romin graph of any
degree uh and they solve this kind of
related question of a bipartite expander
which uh driv to find but it's is pretty
close and it looks like they almost
solve it for for General expanders um
but that's that's that's still a nice
open
question
yeah why can't you identify
ver what do you
mean vertices or something I'm sorry not
but then then you get different degrees
of
course get some this is this this is for
Rion ramion expanders yeah you would get
you might lose half the expand something
like that another thing that's known is
if you take a random to you get like a
one okay good so the last thing I'll say
about this I want is is applications and
there's a ridiculous number of
applications there are applications to
codes to to D randomization to routing
to things involving geometry I think the
general rule is if your problem involves
graphs you should consider looking at
expanded graphs to see if if it has
potential use and even if your problem
doesn't involve graphs but involves
something like geometry or trying to
prove the PCP theorem you should
probably also consider expander graphs
so they're they're really very widely
useful um oh actually no Sor there's one
other thing I want to say which is uh
what Mario said that a billion groups do
not work as K graphs um and many sort of
everyday graphs like the grid and the
you know anything in a dimensions for
kind of a related reason also doesn't
work as an expander graph um so the
geometry of these things is uh is also
pretty interesting I guess James Lee has
done a lot of work on on showing them as
sort of hyper the geometry is sort of
hyperbolic um and but yeah I will not
get into that too much but that's also a
nice a nice area for these things okay
so that was a lot on classical expanders
let me talk about Quantum
expanders um okay sorry one last thing
about classical expanders which is that
we can write this adjacency
Matrix as in a different way as well if
the graph is
dular we can write this as an average of
D
permutations
so uh these are our permutation matrices
and they correspond to uh you know for
each for each vertex you have the D
edges coming out just assign each of
these edges to one of one of D different
permutations one way to say to see this
is if you take the expander graph and
then construct a perfect matching on
that graph that perfect matching will
correspond to a permutation and then
remove all of those edges and you're
left with something that's D minus one
regular and then and then
repeat
um okay
so the quantum analog will kind of build
on this so this says that we have a
collection of D permutation and you
choose one of them at random it mixes
well so a natural Quantum analog is to
say that you have D unitaries and if you
choose one of them at random it'll it'll
mix well so let's define a Quantum
operation to be to apply one of one of D
different
unitaries uh and as with the classical
case we'll ask that this be permission
meaning that the this collection of
unitaries contains its own
inverses um so it might be that you
apply one of D over2 unitaries or you
apply one of their daggers for example
um you could talk about non-mission
Quantum expanders um and it's sort of
interesting to that's something that we
don't we don't know I we don't
understand super well um but there also
aren't that many compelling applications
of that that have led us to to think
about it that much okay so
again we can talk about the spectral gap
of this thing so we can Define 1us
Epsilon to be the second largest is
value of this map because it's
permission it's a it's a map from
matrices to matrices we can think of it
as a linear operator we can talk about
it I values um and just like the
classical characterization where we
subtract the projection out of the
uniform
distribution here the uniform
distribution is like the maximally mixed
state uh and so so the the the channel
That Maps you to the maximally mixed
state is called the depolarizing Channel
um so the depolarizing
channel takes any Matrix
X and replaces it with something
proportional to the identity so take the
trace of X divide sorry divide by by n
so the an N dimensional space and uh and
give the identity so if you put in any
Matrix for example this will output the
maximally mixed state uh
so you can
take this operator subtract the
depolarizing channel and then you remov
the top I value and what you're left
with if you look at
the the 2 to2 Norm of this so that means
the maximum output shaten 2 Norm over
all inputs with shaten to Norm equal to
one then this gives you precisely the
second largest I value it's really just
like what we're doing with matricies
right this this operator Norm is just
what is the largest output two Norm
given an input Vector of two Norm one
we're doing the same thing here except
the outputs and inputs are now matrices
instead of vectors what is
X what is X x is just what these things
are acting
on it you can think of it like a density
Matrix or maybe the difference of two
density matrices or some yeah something
like
that yeah so
the this is equal
to uh
Trace X dagger X all square
rooted another way to say it is that if
you turn X into a
vector it's just the torm of that
vector
um another way to say it is that if you
look at the I values of
X it's the torm of for her Mission
Matrix that's that's the
case
um so it sounds like for it's also it's
also the forus NM it's also the forus NM
yeah are you going to care about the
action on nonion acts at all or because
definition might be slightly different
no I don't think we'll need to use the
non condition X um yeah if this last one
it should be like singular singular
values or something I also just the
value of the ID value might be different
depending on what space
you're
um
maybe um maybe I think not but let's not
sure okay so
um this is a little bit awkward to think
about super operators you know it's
nicer to think about things just like
matrices and in general the map where
you take X to a x
b this we can think of that as so this
is a super operator right an operator
that acts an operator so it takes X it
takes a matrix X to another Matrix axb
but we can just write this out as a
giant Matrix and if we do this
corresponds to the operator a tensor B
transpose um
and according to that
correspondence this map e corresponds
to 1/
D Su over I UI T UI
star so this right multiplication by UI
dagger becomes just tensor UI
star
and uh so this is basically under the
map where you
replace where you replace x with VC X so
another way of saying this is that a
tensor B transpose prior to v x is equal
to V of a x
b that's sort of a more concrete way of
doing that that
isomorphism right so of viewing X as an
N byn Matrix I want to view it as an N
Square dimensional
Vector uh and in that case what apps on
it will will simply be a big
Matrix so is is X positive or it does
not matter it doesn't matter in general
yeah it doesn't
matter
so so if it does not matter then we can
view it as a vector yeah otherwise it
could
you still could it's just the positivity
would be a weirder a weirder but then it
would be an extra Weir condition
yeah
so sorry your notation star is conjugate
so dagger is conjugate transpose and
star is just trans is just conjugate so
if you do dagger and then transpose you
get a
star so okay so let's see how everything
translates into this picture if you
take
the
um right so this is what the expander
becomes what about the identity and what
about the depolarizing channel so the
identity
Matrix that that doesn't work
um so the identity
Matrix
under this map the the vector version of
it looks like the maximally entangled
state right so you could write this as
root
n time
VN where FN is just the
usual Maxim Tangled State on two n
dimensional fyss
um so what is the what do the
depolarizing channel look
like um it basically looks like the
projector onto this state so it looks
like get get map to
this
um so why is that well what the
depolarizing channel does is it takes
the trace of X which you can think of as
the inner product of X with the identity
and so whatever you put in it takes its
inner product with the identity and then
it spits out something that's like the
identity um and then the 1 / n is what
you need to give the right normalization
why is that well the depolarizing
channel if you put in something
proportional to the identity you should
get back what you put out it shouldn't
blow it up or Shrink it and same thing
here if you put in something
proportional to the maximum tangle State
you should just get out exactly what you
put in not times any kind of
scale so this is what the depolarizing
channel maps to so this gives an an
alternate characterization of the
expander condition says that 1 minus
Epsilon is equal
to the norm of the
difference between this operator
and I'm just going to use this as
shorthand just for the projector and
this projector onto the mauline tangle
state where this is now the the infinity
Norm the shat Infinity Norm or the the
largest igen value of this thing as a
matrix okay um
so this so far adjusted the level of of
definitions but from this you get a very
nice application to um to the task of
of by
partite measurement
simulation
so um I got confused yeah I thought you
that you're just using the regular way
to view matrices as vectors but here
you're using something like mov
representation I think you should write
f n or f n instead of just
F here no in the here yeah because it
should be an n² by n² matrix yeah I
guess you know know there's this
convention where if you just write sigh
it stands for the projection on Sai and
I'm I'm just using that
convention uh it's sort of oh it saves
you a lot of writing in the
end um max confusion but it also leaves
to confusion but it's I didn't invent it
it's kind of a lot of people use it and
I think it's it's it's good once you
once you adopt it other uh questions
critiques
um okay so
um so
uh one other way so sorry there's one
other way to interpret it which is look
at expanders what is going to be the
fixed point of this map right if you if
you put in something and you you cut you
multiply it by a bunch of conjugated by
a bunch of unitaries what is going to
stay the same well for sure the identity
GR the maxim mixed state if you multiply
by about of unitaries will stay the same
and what it means to be an expander is
that nothing else does so your
difference from maximally mixed Will Get
shrunk by an expander that's kind of the
definition of it and in this
picture we see something pretty similar
so what is the unique state that is
invariant so suppose we have
this that's true for all this true for
all unitaries U what can you stay about
the s well then it must you can say it
must be the maximally mixed sorry the
maxim entangled State this is the unique
so if this is true for all for all U
that implies that s is equal to the
maximally the Maxim in Tangled State
that's is sort of the unique solution of
that equation just like the identity is
the unique thing that's going to be
invariant under multiplying by all
unitaries and this measures sort of how
good a job these uis are of
of coming close to that ideal that you
would get from averaging over all
unitaries so if I were to replace this
with the average over all unitaries I
would get exactly the projection out of
this but instead if I just average over
some maybe very short list I get an okay
approximation to it where the
approximation is okay and operator Norm
yeah so I don't yet see an advantage to
viewing it as a vector so can you help
me understand why we went down that roof
like what's the point of this equation
no what's the point of you know taking
the density Matrix and flattening it out
as a vector so so far I didn't see any
advantage to that well I guess right
so what did we do what did it what did
it achieve to flatten it out we went
from this equation to this equation so
why is that step great um so let's
consider the following
problem uh which is um you have Alice
and Bob and they share some State s and
they want to make some measurement do it
and they want to measure suppose you
want to measure you want to do a two
outcome
measurement and your povm
outcomes are the projector onto the max
Tangled State and identity minus that
projector so another way of saying it is
you have a state and you want to know is
this the max are we holding are we
sharing the maxim angled date or
something
orthog so one you know you could do a
bell test for example and that would
give you some kind of statistics about
it but suppose you really want to just
perform this this two outcome
measurement as accurately as you can
because Bell tests have some kind of uh
you know you have to do many of them to
together statistics uh what is really
the best you can do um so one thing you
can do if you have a small amount of
quantum
communication is you can use expanders
um
and the idea is suppose that they really
have this state and well yeah maybe I'll
maybe I'll describe I'll write down the
circuit first um and I want to write it
with time going from right to left I
hope that's okay I think it'll it'll
make the equations nicer in a
second
um so here's how it works they share
some State s and they want to know is
this the max Tangled state or something
orthogonal to it and
Alice
begins with a copy of this
state um and
then she uses it to control to do a
controlled usei
here on on her copy of the big F so this
is a small D dimensional register this
is a big and dimensional register then
this continues she sends her copy to Bob
so using a small amount of Quantic
communication she sends this register to
Bob and then he does a
controlled use of I
star so what's going to happen if this
state if this indeed were a masine
tangled State then it would be invariant
under all of the uens or uars so all
these things would do nothing and their
state would stay the same as before
and intuitively if these unitaries
scramble it up really well and this is
orthogonal to a maximally entangled
State then each unitary should sort of
take it to some new orthogonal Direction
and so this thing will become in Tangled
with the post rotated State here and so
that is something you should be able to
detect by looking at this register and
so what Bob will do is he will project
onto the original superposition
so he will kind of he'll do this
projection and kind of output yes if it
succeeds and output no if it doesn't
Okay so let's look at the resulting
measurement
operator um so you have Bob's projection
looks like
this and then identity for the two
systems then you have these controlled
unitaries UJ tensor UJ star and then you
have Alice's
preparation again with
identities and when you put it together
you just get one over I sorry 1 over D
sum of UI tensor UI
star this is exactly the measurement
that they have implemented
with this
protocol when I say the measurement I
mean this is the yes outcome and then
the no outcome is is IUS M okay so they
they want to do this and
instead what they do is
M IUS
M so they approximate the true
measurement with this this protocol and
now the only question is how good an
approximation is this um
and the answer is well how and and so
this means how different is M from the
operator they really wanted which is the
projection onto the maxim tangle State
um and so finally that's the answer to
um's question of you know what's the
point of this alternate way of looking
at it uh you know it's exactly this
equation right this this tells us
exactly how far this protocol is from
what we would like it to be yeah so this
this is just I I think this is this can
be translated to exactly what Mario
showed in his talk right it's a it's a
hamiltonian I think it can be translated
to hamiltonian whose spectral Gap is
something related to Epsilon and whose
uh ground state is is highly entangled
but uh the only the communication is
local it looks to me like it's the same
thing or it can be translated oh yeah
it's a good
point because you
uh right Communication channel could be
like there could be some Hamilton
mediating that and then the controlled
unitary right so the sort of the unique
thing that satisfies it oh yeah is the
is the max is is the highly entangled
state or is is the state is it Maxim
intangle um so yeah what is the size of
the channel That the size of the channel
is log d right okay right so let's um so
just yeah just a followup question uh
could you have expanders which have sort
of so if you just look at at the
expanders on those sides could they have
local
structure local like in terms of two
cubic Gates um yes so you want to ask
can you do it efficiently I'm sorry you
mean like can you do it with an
efficient circuit uh no efficient
circuit I
yeah U you what with set around UI doing
good too
um well what do you mean by local
structure
um so okay uh really the ultimate thing
would be to to if if you could use this
thing as as a as an attempt at trying to
build a counter example to area laws
yeah in small Dimension then the
question is could you have uh Quantum
expanders um on both sides which have a
local structure meaning uh uh that the
circuit itself is local you don't
respect expanders from
local fixed
Dimension
well okay maybe we should no it's it's a
very good question I think
um yeah to get from this to a 2d aial Lo
counter example not 2D maybe no it's a
good question I guess one one yeah so
we're I mean it'd be good to to even
precisely formulate what the condition
on the expander on the expander would be
um
so let me just talk about this protocol
so the communication is log debit um and
the
error is uh Lambda 2 right this is the
the difference between these two things
if it were a ramanan expander I realize
it's a classical we say for classical
then we would have that this would go
like 1 over root D so in other words the
communication would be like log of one
over the
error uh I guess you know you know twice
log one of the eror
um if you had a a Quantum ramion
expander um and I'm a little over time
so I'll just say that Quantum ramion
expanders exist
um
and
the yeah so this is a
um yeah so and so so this this type of
communication is a
and so this is an interesting thing in
terms of communication complexity one
thing we'd like to know is is there a
quantum nuben theorem if you have a a
communication complexity protocol that
uses a ton of entanglement can you
replace that entanglement with some
Faith entanglement that fools it and the
protocol if the protocol only uses like
a really small Amic communication maybe
it won't be able to tell the difference
between a billion epr Pairs and some
other billion Cubit state with much less
entainment sorry what's the classical
numph sorry the classical num theorem
says if you have a a communication
protocol that uses a ton of Randomness
but very little
communication uh actually forget the
amount of communication but has a small
number of inputs so if the input size is
is n but the amount of Randomness is
much much more than that you can replace
all the randomness just with log n
roughly random bits and the protocol
will do almost as well so can something
similar will work quantumly if you have
some protocol that uses tons of
entanglement but say only very little
communication can you get rid of the
extra entanglement so Rahul has an
example of a protocol where
uh something that sort of refutes that
and this can be viewed as another
reputation of this because this is a
protocol
that if use a very small amount of
communication but can test an
unboundedly large entangled State and so
the size of the entangled state has
nothing to do with the amount of
communication needed to tested
um right so that's one implication um so
now um um so this doesn't say anything
about a function problem no no no and so
it's worth pointing out that yaan has a
a very nice result of so what what do we
know about reducing the amount of
communication sorry reducing the amount
of entanglement in communication
complexity I think Yan's result is the
only thing we know uh pretty much which
is if you have something that uses Q
Cubit of communication and an unbounded
amount of entanglement you can replace
it with something that uses no entang
lement and two to the Q classical
communication so at least if the amount
of communication is constant then at
least for communication complexity
purposes entang cannot help an unbounded
amount and so when you put all this
together what this says is if you want
to get rid of entanglement in
communication complexity you cannot do
it in sort of a blackbox way where you
just replace the entangled state with
some fake entangle state but you really
have to kind of look at the details of
what the gates are and and and what the
protocol is
okay so um so that's a bit of aide this
is I think one application expanders you
heard a very nice one from Mario
yesterday um but it's possible that
you've heard the same application twice
uh if we we look at it more more
carefully um another application is in
Matt Hastings original paper that
introduced expanders where he uses it to
construct a spin
chain uh a state with uh
constant correlation
length uh so a state in 1D so like a
spin chain in 1D the correlation length
is constant the
entanglement is uh linear in the number
of of Cubit if if you cut it and it's
the ground state of a gapped hamiltonian
L be at one
with uh that where the the terms act on
many cubits sort of logarithmic in the
number of cubits so if the total number
of Cubit if it's n
cubits then it's it's log
n local so this
is
Hastings
07 was sort of the original motivation
for for quanum span one of the original
motivations for Quantum expanders um and
it's a little bit similar so the tons of
entanglement corresponds to the very
large dimension of expanders and the
short correlation length corresponds to
the large gap of the expanders in in his
construction I think I don't have time
to to really explain it but just to say
if you build a matrix product state
where the matrices involved are
expanders then this is the route to to
doing this
construction uh and there are some
similar features and that there's a kind
of very large
entanglement uh and
uh yeah let me maybe I won't explore
this inur just too much um okay
so all this would be would be worthless
if if these Quantum expanders didn't
exist um but it turns out a lot of the
ideas from classical expanders go
through to the quantum case so if you
pick random a random graph will be an
almost ran classical expander uh and
Matt Hing showed that a random set of
unitaries will be an almost rusan
Quantum expander and that proof is
actually much much easier because uh
basically classical random objects or
sort of random combinatorial objects are
much more likely to collide and have bad
things happen than random uh random
vectors so if you take two random points
uh if you choose two random elements of
an N element sorry two random elements
of an N element set the probability of
collision is 1 n but if I choose two
random n dimensional vectors they're
almost certainly going to be nearly orth
and the probability of deviating from
that is exponentially small in N so
they're just things work out better in a
sense in terms of random objects
there're also explicit ones you can
basically do all these things
efficiently um we don't know everything
quite as well so we don't know how to
get a efficient ramanujan expander but
we know how to get one where the degree
is sort of the square of what it should
be for a ramanujan expander how to do
that efficiently um you mean that the U
are computational right so what you what
we would like is that the parameters be
as good as possible and also if you
build these things out of cubits then
you can do it polinomial in a number of
cubits and we can do it with with
slightly worse parameters um using
similar ideas there's sort of a Quantum
zigzag product uh and there's a um you
can do it based on K graphs and and
using uh representations so what's
this where this
um there's a few different papers so um
there's
one that
um so let's uh okay so there's one just
by me in 2007 that does it for kphs
there's one by David Gross and Yen iser
and somebody else that does it for using
a Quant version of the marulas expander
there's one by
um tashma
and somebody else Benya of Benya that do
the the zigzag product um there's one
the original one by Hastings has a
construction that is you use a classical
tensor product expander and you add a
phase
um and then there's um one yeah that's
that's most of them I think there so by
now there's quite a few constructions
um so anyway so these these
constructions exist and you can do it
efficiently and for things like like
Mario's application where you want it to
be a small number of gates uh it's
actually it's actually quite important
so yeah you said that there's an
advantage in the quantum case because of
lack of collisions to prove to prove
that random ones work it's easier okay
are there other advantages because of
this or
um you mean well it just achieved
something totally different uh it I just
mentioned an advantage in terms of it's
it's easier to construct them um they're
kind of incomparable you know it's not
like if you have a Quantum expander that
will give you a classical expander or
vice versa they're similar but but not
directly comparable
um so okay I should okay I should wrap
up let me um let me mention two other
yeah so um if you looking for qu is it
like the same as looking for unary
design
one right okay soting
theal that's right so the the difference
between a design and an expander is
usually in the uh in the norm that you
that you have here so if you replace
this Infinity Norm with a one Norm then
that would be what you need for a design
and as a result a design you Cann not do
with a constant number of gates the
number of Gates has to sorry a constant
number of of unitaries the number has to
grow with with Dimension however so a
design is strictly stronger than
expander and you can get it because of
replacing Infinity with one you can get
it just by losing a dimension factor and
so some of our methods for constructing
designs are based
on uh basically taking expander powering
it many times and then just accepting
that Dimension L
yeah is a quick summary of your thoughts
about where you know
what I
um I don't know how to make any
connection there
um the it comes up in the classical PCP
because you want to you're applying to
the bits you want an expander on the
bits and you want to replicate their
information all over the case I don't
know know how to do something an how to
even sort of make a St statement that
parse is properly
here one let me tell you the closest I
know how to come to that which
is you can think of this so expanders
are used in
PCP by via codes so and just that's much
much simpler than the PCP is the way
expanders are used to construct aecting
codes so maybe Quantum expanders can be
used to construct Quantum ating codes
um this is in a sense a kind of like
that you can think of this as an error
correcting code that encodes zero
cubits but you just want to know you
know are you in this protected space or
are are you far from it it's sort of
like detecting if there's an error to
this to for example if you have a maxim
entangled State and you want to know if
some errors has happened to it this is a
way of of at least efficiently detecting
it and so one thing I would i' would
like to figure out is can you use an
expander to construct an approximate
Quantum correcting code we know that
approximate Quantum correcting codes
exist with dramatically better
parameters than than exact Quant
correcting codes I think it' be cool if
expanders had some connection there but
it's I don't know how to make that how
to make that more precise but that's
sort of the most concrete thing in that
direction that I'm able to
say
um another
question so
um right so one body of work has been
you know trying to construct these
things uh I've told you about a few sort
of diverse applications of them another
thing you can
do is you can
say suppose you want to consider so
expanders say that if you apply it to a
state then the average of that will go
to what it should do but what if you
want to control the higher moments of
what happens then this is equivalent to
taking this thing and putting a tensor K
here and then here you have to replace
it with something else which I'm not
going to write down but that something
else is what you would get if you
average this over the har measure so
it's no longer a onedimensional
projector but it's some other some other
Beast what you get then is something
called a tensor product expander uh and
because it's an expander where the the
tensor products are controlled and this
is useful for controlling as I said
higher moments which can give you if you
want to get for example a stronger
concentration bound these can be useful
so if you want to prove that the output
of a random Circuit of depth D cannot be
distinguished from the hard from a
totally random unitary by any
distinguishing Circuit of depth less
than the sixth root of d That's how you
would do this because by controlling the
higher moments you can show that the the
any any deviation of the output of this
random Circuit of of this sud random
circuit from from what You' get from the
average must get ressed by by an amount
that that relates to uh to how many
higher moments you can control so I
really don't have time to get into this
but this is sort of if you want to ask
where things gone since expanders were
introduced several years ago One
Direction is tens of product expanders
of controlling higher moments another
question is maybe your application
doesn't call for moments but it calls
for some more specific things so maybe
want you want to build an an error
correcting code or you want to do
decoupling uh and so there's been a lot
of work by by Brown and fzy and also by
by ber of fzy Schultz and and Sher on
showing that if you do if you have
random circuits okay so there's a paper
of me Fernando and Miha heski that shows
that that random circuits give you T of
product expanders but this work by Brown
and fzy and and and
collaborators shows that in some cases
expanders give you more than you need so
expanders kind of control you know these
operators say whatever you feed in this
will do the right thing times of
expanders of the same thing they kind of
you control all of the higher order
moments and I think this has sort of
been a good starting point but then for
some applications you might say well I
don't need to control all the higher
moments for my application I just need
to compute this maybe it is a degree K
quantity but it's a more specific
quantity and I can I can do something
more refined there and so this work by
by Brown and fuzzy uh has has been a
very nice recent example in that
direction where instead of controlling
all the higher moments you you you just
make some kind of specific statement
about it and kind of the general area
that this is is the area of of of pseudo
randomness of trying to say instead of
having a hard uniform unitary can I can
I simulate it with some much smaller
amount of Randomness and expanders are
kind of a nice very general tool for it
um tend to product expands are another
nice General tool but I think going
forward we'll start to see kind of more
specialized ones uh adapted to the
particular application in mind okay so
thanks for your patience I I'll stop
here
so you talked about Quantum
ramanujan Xander but like classically
you said that ramanujan xanders are very
natural because of the infinite tree
yeah and so that's what sets that's uh
whatever two
times minus
one/ uh but so in
there is no infinite tree or so what
would be the analog of that so what what
sets the B for there sort of is so
suppose B suppose you take e to the to
the m power of of X so this corresponds
to applying a bunch of end times
sampling a random unitary and applying
it and I said that this collection of
unitaries contains its own inverses so
there's always a chance that you apply
unary and then you apply that unary as
inverse and you come back to where you
are or you apply U1 and then U2 and then
U2 dagger and then U1 dagger and you
come back to where you are so there is
again a notion of a return probability
and it it Ares in exactly the same way
and then and then you do some
conversation and the and you get this
ultimate limit for what you get what you
can get for it's the same calculation
the same return probability the same
calculation it's kind of like you know
you apply a bunch of unitaries and it
could be that
it's trivially equal to the identity
because just things just canel or it
could be that it depends on the
particular unitaries you use and maybe
it's close to Identity maybe it's not
and though in the most optimistic case
you say if it's not trivially equal to
the identity then it's as scrambling as
possible and that's that will give you
the the ramion Bound for the quantum Cas
well and so maybe a related question is
that well in the AL M or whatever Cher B
like you connected the
uh this value Gap with something
combinatorial like so for this
conductance so is there like any notion
or any analog of that this so we have
seen the I value there but is there like
any yeah it's a good question so there
we have one with Frank it looks
essentially the same you just replace
this with like a projector I guess or
projector minus
identity yeah um oh that's good to know
is that is that published
yeah it's in the sky Square paper
from but it's hidden
okay yeah yeah so uh let's come back to
your definition of the U this spectral
Gap and energy so it seems to me it's
more natural to use the diamond Norm
instead of the 2 to2 Norm good and it it
seems in principle it's possible that
you could have a Quantum expander in
that but not in this sense right good so
the diamond Norm is what you would we
usually call those designs okay
and
there's it's just a for a different set
of applications right
um
and one difference is that constant
degree becomes constant D becomes
impossible you have to have D growing
with P if you want a good Diamond Norm
approximation and why is that well if
you just put in a pure state
then you apply a collection of D
different unitaries and you're in
dimension
n how are you going to look close to the
maxim mixed date even if you knew what
the input was and you had to choose the
unitar accordingly you're not going to
be close to the maximum mix date unless
D is at least n * 1us Epsilon I guess
that's when you restrict your uh
operation to be the form of
U mixture of you de uh yeah okay so
that's one thing you could do is you
could relax it just say take let them be
any Crouch operators but nevertheless
the the rank of the resulting output
density Matrix would be at most D and so
again you you would you would have that
b um so this is a I don't want to say
it's not important designs are very
useful often times we actually care
about designs um one thing I didn't talk
about is our K designs um and right now
the only way we know how to show the
existence of K designs is via K tensor
product expanders
so we know how to construct a k tens of
product expander and then you repeat it
many times amplify it and then you just
when you go to designs you just lose a
dimension Factor um but it's possible
that as brown and fzy did for two
designs that we'll be able to kind of
get a more direct argument for K designs
that'll make it more efficient but in
general the answer is yes these are
valuable things um they're related but
they're kind of off by Dimension factor
and so the whole a lot of what we want
to do for expanders is get something
that sort of constant degree
completely impossible for designs and
for expanders it can be valuable for
things like what Mario talked about
yesterday so so one way to characterize
designs is to say that they look
completely random against like like so a
k design is some set of unitaries that
looks par random against all degree K
polinomial functions on the unitary
group for a suitable definition of
polinomial function that's right ex is
there a way that you can phrase the
expansion condition in terms of looking
completely random against some
particular particular well defined class
of functions so if you have a perfect
design or perfect expander like you know
Epsilon is equal to to uh I guess in
this case one you know ltitude to zero
those are the same thing right but I me
so is there a way to phrase it let's say
that so so like ramanan expanders would
be like analogous to a design so you
could def find some class of functions
so that they look perfect but it's not
all
functions no it's I mean it's uh
no I mean
there yes it's not
doesn't I don't think so but I'm not
sure so yeah so you can describe this in
terms of indistinguishability a design
is something where whatever the input is
the output is is indistinguishable
there's another way of you know one way
thing about expanders is that you're
kind of adding randomness of the system
as efficiently as possible so another
thing they relate to is extractors where
Maybe you have some state which is
pretty random but you want to make it
really look say because there's an
adversary you want to make it look
totally random and so you want to
basically add entropy to it and expander
ramenu and expander is the most
efficient kind of general purpose way of
doing this if you didn't know anything
about the state you just want to
increase its ru2 entropy an expander
would be the best way to do this but you
still only increase it at the rate that
you put in you put in randomness and so
if you start from a pure State and you
just add a little bit of Randomness to
it you'll have very efficiently added
Randomness but you won't have gotten all
the way to the end so design kind of
measures how well do you get all the way
to the end whatever you put in it just
makes it completely random whereas for
an expander that's kind of not the goal
the goal is to like take some steps
towards it but deliberately don't make D
too big and so as a result you you know
you're not fully randomizing you're just
kind of increasing the amount of
randomness
okay let's CA
again